what's up guys welcome to a very unique
situation here
um I'm calling this JK overtime
I guess I'm calling it JK overtime as
well which is ironic because we're not
being paid over time to be here but we
are going over the usual amount of time
that these episodes go which is what a
lot of people have been asking for for a
very long time they've been like over
time episodes are too short so then
we're like why don't we get together on
an off day and just go Limitless and
just talk about whatever you feel like
especially because we're still in
California
compared to some people who left this
business and abandoned it a while ago
yeah and moved on to a better place
sounds like they died
dude this is this is it we were just
talking about this off camera we were
talking about the idea that uh we can
only sometimes go into a topic or go so
deep based off of two things one is time
at our longest episodes are like roughly
like 20 minutes our otrs right off the
records for all the fans out there but
you know 20 minutes only goes so deep
but then the second thing is that this
whole place is just kidding new so the
second you even get remotely deep into
something you're gonna get dunked on
right yeah you kind of have to in a way
which is funny because I remember that
brings up this really odd thing but a
long time ago we had done this episode
that was about uh why can't Asian guys
date white women or something and the
first time we did it we were joking and
all the comments were like why aren't
you why are you guys joking about that
and people
I really wanted to know like I wanted
help with this problem but you guys just
[__] around
and um and then we recently redid it and
then we were like okay let's do it again
like months later but let's not joke and
let's actually address the issue and
then people are like oh damn like this
is what I wanted thank you so much but
then people who are really close to us
were like yo that was the most boring
episode
so I was like you should never really
win but you know also like you said we
don't really get too far past the
Earth's crust you know what I mean in
that amount of time I mean it's called
just kidding news anytime anybody I
think says why are you joking about that
I think you have to like really think
about the brand and the title
um and just ask yourself why I stopped
by just kidding news
um but you know to even just expand the
the the ecosystem and just like where
we're all at and also we're all
expansive people everybody has a depth
to them uh outside of like the jokes and
stuff you know
um maybe adding this little segment of
longer conversation of our overtime uh
will be able to satisfy some of those
people that are looking for a little bit
more hell yeah also I think it's cool
that we know we're always focusing on
guests or when we're all together we're
focusing on the collective Dynamic but
we never really get to talk like one to
one and kind of just go deeper you know
like a lot of people don't realize how
well we know each other
you know and how long we've known each
other
uh let's put a year to it we're probably
I'm gonna have to jog my own memory I'm
not even telling a story I'm like
discovering myself let's put a year to
it yeah uh
I'm thinking like oh six dude 2006.
yeah it might be osis I definitely you
were a sophomore in in college I think
yeah I was yeah sophomore in college for
0.506 I definitely heard about you like
0506 for sure because
oh no I was definitely uh Victor Kim
yeah obviously was a guy who's uh
showing me some of your Clips
um and we were watching this cat out of
Ryan and this cat named ryanime he's
from the OC you know what I mean so when
you're talking about like a lot of other
b-boys and stuff like that in the scene
at that time they said I was from the OC
yeah oh that's funny well uh or from
from Southern California and we're in
the area because you know we were
watching people from like Korea yeah
yeah yeah we were watching people from
France you know what I mean anytime like
this is before YouTube so when we're
going on like onesipher.com or bibo
world.com or whatever forums had like
b-boy clips and Victor would be just
showing me everything see what Mike you
know what I mean we would just be
[__] ingesting as much content as
possible I do specifically you or stand
out because I was like one there's a guy
who has his hair that I don't know how
he has Cloud Strife here he has it yeah
and then he's capable of doing like
really flexible stuff with his leg where
he does his thing where he puts his
[__] foot on his shoulder and like
magically brings his [__] foot over
here or like does the thing where he
like spins on his like elbow and stuff
you know this before I saw like the head
flip oh wow and I was just like seeing
these moves and uh I think maybe at the
time I was maybe equating it to like uh
circus runaways you know yeah just like
Sierra yeah flexible kind of Counter
Culture breaking exactly you know you
were like punk rocker type like either
like tight jeans ripped up you had so
much holes on all my clothes there was
such an edginess you had like like uh
arm socks there like wow you remember
that actually like bracelets everywhere
you just had a look bro I got called Gay
all the time every [__] every day of my
life as I would leave the house my dad
but yeah so like oh five oh six I was I
was hearing about you but yeah it wasn't
I don't think I met you
did I meet you before hawk I I don't
know I don't know if who came first
because Hawk met Mike I think very early
on yeah so the crazy thing is you Victor
Kim Mike song were like the three
freaking Amigos man and uh that was like
the triplet and when I met Victor that's
pretty much when I kind of met you and
Mike yeah and you guys are like
Inseparable back then and Victor is a
guy that was from my crew Quest Crew but
he ended up disappearing we'll get into
that later but um
but Victor
my hearing just disappeared
uh yeah that's long story short he
disappeared but Victor Anthony Mike
lived together in college and uh that
was the Holy Trinity well I don't know
about holy
um yes we were here
but yeah we were we were click you know
we all met our freshman year at College
in 2004 at UCI
um dance was for sure the definitive
thing that like brought us together
um Mike asked us to participate in a
casa Korean American student
associations like dance off so it's a
freshman dance off
um he asked us to join the the Korean
Association crew to to do their freshman
dance off we're literally that club puts
freshmen together puts a routine on them
they compete at some [__] club in L.A
somewhere and it's like the schools that
battle battle it out like yeah versus
UCLA we do this for for Chinese
Association too for all count stuff
um but same thing this is for freshmen
for Koreans we were so cocky even me who
had never danced so [__] ever already
I was I was in a squad with like Mike
and Victor so I was like oh my God like
you know I just yeah yeah it's dripping
with ego you know for no reason as an
incoming freshman um thinking we were
hella tired I was not for sure I was
worst always will be probably
um but uh we go and UCLA smokes us and
like it just
it just a Nile I remember we just got
destroyed that day but it was so funny
because I think people that go through
struggle get closer than people who just
share like you know wins and stuff
totally um and I remember that being
really the Catapult of like my dance
Journey oh obviously it wasn't a career
a journey of Revenge you would say
low-key yeah and to the point where I
was so like I'm I'm so petty I'm like
Steve Petty almost that when I remember
I remember promising to myself that I
would come back every year and assist a
freshman to be oh that's still L.A and
we did that every year I came back and I
was a part of cost of freshman dance-off
as like a choreographer or whatever oh
we won every single time I've always
been curious what your motivation was to
keep helping
that that was a very Petty one but there
there is there was like maybe you know
as a young kind of like about to be like
director of different things in dance
yeah I think that there was like a
natural calling for me to want to put
myself in that position to you know like
create direct figure things out you know
what I mean like the strategy of
Showmanship and competition is always a
fun thing for me you know um but point
is going back to us three going through
stuff like that and then just like
clicking up and then dancing because all
of us went separate ways but still
stayed homies right like yeah uh Mike
went on to audition for Cabo modern I
went on to audition for cadc Victor
ended up joining a sixth step with you
you know yeah which is crazy that you
guys are all in different teams and it's
crazy that as long as I've known you
we've always been on different teams but
very close circles yeah like we had the
same friends but we never like did
performances together or anything yeah
to the point where you know you you were
freaking living with with Victor and
Mike and every everybody in that house
which we'll get to in a second too but
the cool thing about your mama crew I
think as well is that that's how we like
your mom Cruise even what brought me
here and that's like JK right right
right that's what your mom too yeah
didn't get booked to be on the tick tick
tour tick tick to I believe and we got
Chad and can being our text yay in the
background for periodics periodix was
just on a tear and they were doing their
second tour in Australia where their
headline is called the tiktik Tour Part
Two I believe
um and that's where Just Kidding Films
was being brought out so like barjo and
Gio
um and that's when like Joseph Vincent
J.R Aquino The Architects had like puss
on it
um to who else was there Shawnee damn
just all-time All-Stars you know and
then yo mama crew and Mike couldn't make
it to that particular event so it was
just me Victor and then Lawrence Cal
because Lauren subbed in for Mike and we
did a show there and that's literally
how I met like you know Bart Joe and Geo
and stuff and since then it was like
you know coming onto JK films becoming a
member of JK news all this stuff that's
literally the whole story but it came
from Yo Mama crew being like our thing
wasn't even kinjas dude it's so funny
that like I feel like my first
impression of you looking back like this
is 2006 or 2007 how old were you at that
time sophomore in college sophomore
College makes me what like 1920. dude my
impression view I thought you were like
The Brainiac guy I thought you were like
the smart guy
like you had Victor Mike and you and for
some reason I think I had gotten really
close to Victor because he was always
coming to practice and [__] but then
like
um and then I knew Mike a little because
I'd went to Kaaba parties yeah and and
like talked to him there but I didn't
really know you so I just assumed that
you were quieter than them so I just
assumed you were smarter
so I was like oh that that's a smart guy
the caller guys now you know
louder than them so I mean I must be I
didn't know that for years I didn't know
that until I moved in with uh until like
2000 I want to say like eight 2009 when
I moved to Invicta is when I really
heard your actual voice
hahaha
and I was like oh damn this guy's cool
dude uh similarly uh
I you were just a Mystique to me like uh
like just a very a powerful and edgy
Aura of an image but I never really like
knew that you were very much so a
[__] goofball freaking dork yeah
cause like when you uh if you don't like
actually let's talk about the dance part
about our expressive nature if somebody
doesn't know you and they see your dance
style it is both uh that's why me and
Mike always call it sacrificial because
you're [__] throwing your body yeah
like you're that's like that's my
favorite that's painful that looks like
it would be painful for a number of
everybody else on the planet
um but when you do it like that and you
don't know who you are obviously you
look very very edgy and like oh a
certain type of rough right you know
what I'm saying one-man Mosh Pit kind of
kind of so you don't know yeah and then
like
when you learn about you when you get to
know you and you realize that this guy's
willing to do those moves but like
I don't know like you know onesie or an
address or like you know against the
wall or break different things that's
totally different I'm like this was a
freaking goofball you know um
and it wasn't until I feel like
well there's in many instances but
what really got me was your [__] IG
stories oh wow that later that was like
well it's because all the other states
15 years later all the other stuff was
still really cool oh wow
you guys are ABDC Champions and you're
like living at foo's house you know what
I mean yeah you used to come to those
that was dope yes yes I did great for
coming or like hosting like the
Halloween parties for Quest yeah like um
or playing the piano like [__]
reincarnated Mozart like there were
elements of things that you would do
that were very standout edgy and like
really amazing but it didn't necessarily
paint like goofball oh or or goofballs
is too too [__] laxidasical word but
it's just there's very a funny Charisma
wow you know what's weird is like I
think also I was so shy around you guys
when remember when I lived with uh I
think we were living in Costa Mesa and
it was like all your friends lived in
the house I lived in and you would come
over Tony Tran would come over and like
I was always so shy to interact with you
guys because I didn't know the dynamic
and maybe that's why I thought you were
just a nerd because I was like he's like
really shy and not coming out but
everything there's like it's like all
Final Fantasy there's like nothing but
like gameplay that I'm like only
learning that you're like a [__] game
nerd I would always just be in my room
playing video games when you guys are
over and then I would always be like man
I hope one of those dudes knocks on the
door and asks if they can play but like
because I didn't know how to [__]
invite you guys in but like in my head
I'm like yeah maybe at some point I'll
just turn this [__] up and they'll hear
Mario and they'll go hey what are you
doing there and Bully their way into the
room and I can go no guys yeah we
probably should have gotten a lot closer
a lot sooner yeah but you know life
works the way that it works it's because
there were so many different webs like
you guys are connected through UCI
through like the uh the frats through so
many different ways and I was like ah
these guys are cool my uh my true uh and
and I say again I I go back to the to
the
um the charismatic funny all this
personality stuff because you taking so
much time in things like IG stories to
like write things out showcase stories
to be totally disposed yeah just crack
up about stuff so there's like a
particular articulation of that
experience but like what my real game
changing experience with you was like in
terms of like I think what truly
elevated our friendship are uh
definitely
two things
one was the piano man yeah so yeah when
I was when I was directing culture shock
La back in
2011 to like 12 13 14. I don't know
something like that around that time
frame
um yeah I had the greatest time you know
what I mean it was like uh it wasn't
necessarily for work it wasn't like uh
this like career but it was like a
non-profit hip-hop education
organization you know what I mean that
goes out to like underserved communities
and like uses the best yeah you know it
was just good people so we did the best
with what we could as a non-profit to
put together like fun shows and stuff
but at the end of the day like as a
Creator I'm still trying to like do
something different do something fresh
you know what I mean yeah uh and so I
get this idea to uh and again this idea
spawned because of me knowing you and
your ability I you know when like you
you're only as good as like you know as
a cook like the the the ingredients that
you have time so of course you got your
skills but like with whatever you have
right I mean you you were in my circle
of vicinity and it just like was the the
Ember to a flame that eventually became
like a forest fire of an idea but like I
was like man
like Ryan can basically hear any song
and compose like like variations of that
song of that tune to make it both
original and fresh and and noticeable of
what it is and then he can also mash it
into like 18 other songs that you
request and like that's imagine like
being a dance team director and then
being like these are the six songs we
want to compete to and then make a mega
mix that's already hard as [__] for
somebody to like figure out transitions
when the bpms are different or when the
mood doesn't make this the right you
know that's why you always get these
Mega mixes of just random sounds but
when you're doing it music like actually
musically with like piano keys and stuff
like that it's you you only have the one
instrument and this is how I perceived
it you know you don't get to add like
you know this [__] all these hi-hats
to your crazy booms of uh giant
exploring it's just the the keys that
you're playing with so you actually had
to compose this entire like Symphony for
us yeah that was I feel like that came
in a real really really good time
because like so like you and Mike
basically came over and you guys are
like hey so you know how you can just
play Anything Can you just like chain
all these songs together and it was like
16 something songs and I was like yeah
sure but like that's something I always
wanted to do in the dance community and
never got to do it because I always felt
like oh if if I want to do that I would
have to be the one to bring it up and
that sounds so like I guess like selfish
to be like hey guys when we all dance to
my [__] like that would never happen in
a million years but then for us yeah
that you asking me was like it the
timing was amazing because I think I was
still super bummed out at that time
because I was living I had to move back
home because on tour I I tore my ACL and
then I yeah and then I healed for like a
year and I wasn't dancing or doing that
much so I was living at home in Downey I
remember you guys came over to my actual
parents house I was like Mom this is
Anthony and Mike we're gonna go in my
room now and make a show
you want to eat later
like super like I felt like a kid I was
like God damn it and then um when you
said you wanted to do this thing I
remember the first thing was like your
example was like or Darren you and
Darren and Mike your example was like
can you do something like Sam Smith
mixed with Final Fantasy and I was like
are you are you jerking me off right now
because I just came like it was like the
the requests were so on brand with like
[__] that I genuinely enjoy doing which
is why I was like yes all across the
board no matter what like I would do
this every time like 100 yeah that's
actually nice to know um in a funny way
because uh not to say this takes
anything away but I thought you were
doing it just because you were super
nice no not necessarily because like
that was like your pocket of what you
would enjoy in that dude that is the
most pocket thing I've ever done in my
life so like for people that don't know
like that's amazing one of my jobs is I
I do performance mixes for stage and TV
and movies uh and then and it's kind of
like after doing Quest mixes for so long
and six step mixes certain other uh
people like Olympic skaters or people
that um do Ballroom or whatever they're
just like hey I want a mix like that for
what I do so then I'll do it for uh like
the Chinese the Chinese TV shows or for
um uh for the UCLA gymnastics like it's
it's the same formula but very rarely do
I ever get to go full piano very rarely
because nobody it sounds like your
foundation like your basis for all of it
that's underneath all everything I do so
like it's it's basically the manual it's
like the stick shift version of the
automatic which would be like digital to
me that's [__] crazy and for
everybody who doesn't know like I like
to think and again without any offense I
like to think that Brian plays piano
better than he dances and I think he
dances obviously award-winning messed up
bro award-winning Champion right here I
honestly think I I think I I do too not
that's not to mean like I'm so good but
I think just the amount of years I've
spent for piano has been like what since
age six dude I I I can still go back to
that culture shock show and watch it
the music
uh it's it's crazy because you know it's
like that weird [__] in your brain
chemically or whatever it's like music
can also like like smell it can bring
back memory yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
seeing the videos like oh yeah of course
it's nostalgic dude but hearing the
music gives me the feeling of that time
it like totally holds on to that era and
that time frame and it puts every
emotion back into play seeing you guys
do it was like another thing though
because I hadn't watched I didn't I
purposely didn't want to watch anything
like it you guys were sending me like
rehearsal [__] I was like I don't want
to see none of that I want to I want to
see it at the show yeah and I like saved
my virginity for that and once it once
it went I was like I think I cried bro I
was like this is a dream come true for
me
and I will never tell them because I'm
not gay we went we lived so I went so
far in the requests like I think just
having somebody who is like willing
willing one talented too and then just
like knew that I like you could deliver
it I think I was going I was almost
abusive no nothing because because it
was like aging uh can you go into Jaws
here because I'm gonna buy a a remote
control blow up balloon shark do you
remember that [__] yes and then I
literally got this blow up shark that
you literally it blows up and then it's
got a little machine fan that's on it
and then you can RC it yeah and then we
threw it into the stage and then we had
to fly over the crowd and it's like
because I wanted to do this stupid
little gimmick Ryan had to mix in the
Jaws theme and then there was also a
moment where it's like we want to have
like a Superman and you know what I mean
like a guy literally comes back there's
a whole rewind section
boat comes in and it's like super man
there's it was maybe even a backs of the
future moment yeah you know there was
just things that we thought were were
cool but because we had somebody who I
just knew could do it we were able to
exercise that creatively I loved every
single request like if even if it
sounded like more of uh of a job I love
to do it because that's my favorite
thing is when you know like the when I
would stream and I would just freestyle
music and then people would ask for like
I don't know Sandstorm mixed with Fergie
like I love [__] that doesn't make sense
and it's difficult to do and every time
you were like
sorry but can we please I was like [__]
yeah let's do it what is that impression
it's dainty Anthony
I hate to be a burden
I am a little [__] like that no it was
like I I loved it because also
um culture shock got like at the time
had so many of my friends in it like
Chris quenza Jolie Scarlett yeah yeah
like so many people that I knew and then
and then Bo and Jillian and then it was
and Darren and you just could name them
forever but it was so cool it was like
seeing a mashup of time and people that
I've known and it was it was like Out of
Body Experience seeing it so it's called
The Piano Man and it's on I think it's
on YouTube still yeah it's on YouTube
yeah I love that's because to this day
is still probably one of my favorite
Creations ever but I think that again
that just brings me back to a time where
I think my career hadn't like
taken off by any means
um so I I think as a Creator I was I was
so free of any like pressures yeah and I
think that was like the last time for me
personally where I feel um I didn't have
to think about anything beyond creation
and joy you know and not to say that I
didn't do anything better in the future
but it's just like as an artist right
when you mix your you know it is when
you mix profession with your your
Artistry there it just it's just a
different cocktail no matter what like
you know you put two different colors of
ingredients into something it's just
gonna be a new color right like you and
you can't separate those things all the
time those are always going to be some
sort of like blend back and forth but
that was like at a time where I feel
like it was the last step right before
my actual like career in dance was gonna
take off so I felt like I had the
ambition and the vision without the the
whatever pressures of like needing to
outdo myself or you know make money off
of it or anything like that so it was it
was like one of my favorite times in my
entire dance Journey dude I didn't know
that that's cool I didn't know that you
looked at it with that much like value
because I did I I definitely didn't talk
about it too much but do the Piano Man
is for sure one of my most uh
it's just the best time it's one of the
best times I remember there was this
moment where
um we're rehearsing at but he's on
Utopia down in like Torrance right yeah
and uh I'm in the big room with like the
main rest of the team and like you know
mini shock Mighty shocks future shots
all the little kids and we're putting
together different parts of the number
or whatever right
um not not meetings and minus that's
beneficial but just you know like uh all
just like different segments with the
other team and then I have Bo and
Jillian go work on their mini duet
section in just like one of the smaller
rooms yeah so I just give them a couple
hours or whatever you know and then uh
as the team's working on stuff I go out
and I'm checking on them and they
they're like sweating the music just
played and again everywhere in all these
Studio rooms like your mix is playing
for different things right so it's just
such a cool thing to like also just know
we have like original music on this in a
unique yeah yeah and then they're like
sweating they come out I'm like how you
doing they're like you want So You Think
You Can Dance or what you know what I
mean because they knew that what they
had just put together was just so fun
and but it was also it was a big ask you
know like in these Community
competitions and shows oftentimes people
what they just choreograph segment 30 40
people learn it and then it's like you
present the choreo it's never so focused
on and especially during this is like 10
years ago you know I wasn't so focused
on a small amount of people right but
I'm over here knowing what Bo and
Jillian can do as individuals and
knowing the magic that like nobody needs
to support that actually everybody needs
to get out of the way to see the street
yeah right you know what I'm saying
stars for sure just like having that
confidence too same thing like like you
mentioned just a bunch of our friends
just in that era and that time just
knowing that you could rely on the
people whether it's like on the dance
floor or composing the music to put this
whole thing together and collaborate I
think that that also was such a joyous
thing in the in the early days did you
never want to uh compete on like or
audition for like those TV dance shows
that were popping up left and right back
in the day
um
I not really because I also know that
when I got signed to an agent and I did
like auditions and I told the story on
JK news too like auditions wasn't ever
really my favorite that wasn't your
thing and I also think it's because I
don't
hot take but just for the sake of like
this conversation I don't think like I'm
like me being a dancer is my thing I
think I love creating oh okay you know
what I'm saying I do love things like
choreographing and sequencing Combos and
putting them together and seeing it
happen but even me particularly like
choreographing stuff and then like
needing to be at the Forefront of it
like that's not that's not necessarily
like this is me this is what I do
actually like even my heart now yearns
to create more and not be visually like
the person who's doing that choreography
and even choreography I think is too
small a word um nowadays too I just like
uh
starting at zero and then a product gets
finished yeah yeah right and the process
is always different and that's what's
fun to me but like when the product is
done I just like knowing that I created
something but like I never saw myself
you don't want to be the product
basically not necessarily like and I I
also just don't think I trained like
that I don't train the way certain
people train like where where some
people and respectively so that they put
in so many hours in training into like
their sessions figuring out their combos
their moves their signature moves like
the physicality and the technique of
certain things like I think I put in the
same amount of time to things like
sequencing yeah yeah yeah or or two
things like you know if it wasn't
physically difficult it was mentally
Innovative or unique or stand out-ish
like I think I put in a lot of times and
I just enjoyed that and I would Revere
like the people that put in a lot of
time to their movement technique you
know what I'm saying but that's why you
don't see me in things like you know
just a bunch of freestyle battles or
jams all the time because I enjoy that
as a fan yeah but that's that has
nothing to do with like Anthony leave
the dancer choreographer changes or
whatever that's just me as a dance fan
yeah yeah you know what I'm saying but I
don't put in that time I don't put in
that same job I don't have that ambition
wasn't it crazy I feel like no I don't
know if any generation will have it
exactly the same way but it was a trip
growing up in the dance industry and and
community and slowly seeing different
pockets of friends just get famous
that was such a like it was a shock
every time every time people care about
us you know like it like our world and
then you'll just see like all of a
sudden Yuri is this like Superstar and
then you know Ben's up here and like all
these people that were people that we
thought were knew were Superstars
totally and then they just like blow up
it was crazy to see dude I remember and
again not to like [__] sound like the
old people but it's okay we are the only
people that's true like my first YouTube
video I think I posted in 2005. yeah
right and um I remember when we posted
this like remake of the yo Chris Brown
music video uh I remember we filmed it
we filmed it in like four hours we
edited in four hours I remember thinking
to ourselves like whoa dude eight hours
we finished a video and I was a film
major
so like film major I was a film major
but throughout UCI the whole time
um my first two years I was Undeclared
undecided oh and then I declared if I
didn't know that cool so I was a film
media studies major under the school of
humanities so I was going to things like
Production 101 and you know this is like
mini DVS this is like actual film at the
time where you had to like convert it
into a digital file and if you [__] up
or you know what I mean like you're
losing your entire project rendering
takes overnight for certain things at
like 480p like we were not in a [__]
professional era like it is today where
everybody can do way better work on just
your cell phone like this is like you
had to work your ass off to put a One
Clip with another clip and then put
music on it you know what I'm saying and
then make it shareable as an edit at the
time and so you know during this time
that there were things like Mega
upload.com or whatever to try and share
files but then when YouTube was new I
remember uploading that video
and when there was like 15 views on it
because we like sent it out to the
homies we're like yeah dude our homies
are seeing
it's like so happy right and then when
like there was 50 views I remember like
the slight confusion of like
you did you send this to anybody else
yeah and then when there's like 150 or
500 views I remember I remember I
believe you know I remember hitting up
Mike and just being like Yo dude like I
ain't got 500 friends I don't know
what's going on right now yeah you know
so like just being in that time where
and then I went to store a spot like
that following summer student parent
orientation program and I'm a staffer
right for UCI and then I'm like we're
walking around the cafeteria I'm holding
my tray of food and somebody comes up to
me and they're like are you Anthony Lee
and this is the very first time that
ever that's the very very first one I
remember it was out at [__] cafeteria
at UCI like are you Anthony Lee I'm like
did I do something wrong and this is way
before people started adding [__] hinges
at the end of that right yes yeah that
didn't happen until [__] Steve
um
I wish Steve was never born but um other
than that right
um in the cafeteria at school yeah and
and I I genuinely this never happened
before so I thought it just something
stupid or wrong you know what I mean
that was the easiest place to equate
something too and they're like did you
do the yo Chris Brown music video remake
and I was like whoa yeah right and
they're like yeah
um I saw you at our high school rally at
Cerritos High School oh [__] because you
remember okay you remember what a
[__] High School pep rally yeah yeah
like I remember thinking of High School
pep rally was like if you were anybody
who's anybody like and you were featured
a high school that's like a big that's a
big deal yeah you're a big man on
Captain yeah you're like yeah literally
a a mega star you know and then
somebody's like yeah Cerritos High
School and again I I grew up around the
Cerritos High School area too you know
it's like wait what like why would
anyone play our video at a high school
pep rally and just thinking like yo
we're in a totally different time you
know what I mean so seeing people just
become quote unquote something yeah was
just and and my closest connection was
my song right so when ABDC 2008 season
one happens on MTV and I remember he's
on a break from the show uh so I'm like
yo let's go to dmbs because that was
that was what US UCI kids would do right
yeah yeah you want to go for the drinks
let's go to dmbs and we [__] go to
dmbs and I [__] you not like like all
these Asian cats Frat Boys all these fat
people and stuff like that all these
random fans would be like oh my God you
Mike song from Kaaba and this was the
first time [__] like this was really
happening and it was just such a trip
yeah you know like I was never quicker
to be like I'll take a photo for you
guys you know what I mean just like what
is this Mike's song let's go you know
I'm so happy for Mike but at the same
time I was like I was pretty jealous not
of like like jealous like I didn't want
them to rise I was like
the feeling of people coming up to me
going yo you ever seen this team Cobble
modern and it's the same [__] I've been
telling them for years and they just
didn't listen it's like it made me mad
to be like oh now you're now you care
about it you know what I mean like
immaturely known though you know yeah
right right what a what a phenomenon
a [__] phenomenon yeah it was massive
but yeah who would have known you know
you know it was a [__]
really really wild time too I think
um
it was just these TV shows for dancers
like we talk about this on like
different pods but like it just
it wasn't just about people getting
famous it like shifted and changed the
culture of the industry right no like we
we barely mentioned some of these topics
before in JK news but like a dance level
Asian suddenly becoming a thing yeah to
like you know back in the day when
people would go out and teach in like
Europe and stuff like that everything
was about like Britney Spears
choreographer or like Janet Jackson
chore up for JT or whatever and it
wouldn't even sometimes mention the name
of who that choreographer was it was the
credit was more important than the
person yeah and Artistry and like it
wasn't until these dance shows that that
changed yeah and witnessing that was
also like whoa because nobody was
interested until the dance shows came
along
what was uh your first moment for you
like where you're like holy [__] this is
like this is the ride you know what it
was it was it was um because when I I
did so you think you could answer the
very very first season 2005.
prior to that I'd never done any
audition I'd never had a professional
job like of any type I didn't even know
choreography counts very well the
maximum I did was on six step as a
competitor and of course we found ways
around learning how to count but um the
the shock of being on that show and this
was like a thing maybe that only applies
back then but going on the forums so so
you think your dance used to have its
own Forum
um but now it doesn't you don't need
[__] like that for anything but yeah
back then all the communication about
the show whether fans are discussing it
all took place on the fox.com website
and it so he think had its own like
thread and I remember going on there
while I was still competing and I was
sequestered so I couldn't go anywhere I
lived in the hotel uh you weren't
allowed to see anybody uh and then we
would all just the
um contestants would just go on the
Forum to see what people are saying
about us at the time I only saw social
media was Myspace and back back in the
day they had a backwards view on it so
networks would make you delete your
Myspace if you were doing something like
this if you're doing idle if you're
doing anything you would have to delete
it which doesn't make any sense but yeah
they saw it so backwards so we deleted
it no we had no way of fans talking to
us or telling us nothing you go on the
Forum and then you just read what people
are saying about you and then the the
first time I saw somebody say oh yeah
I'm a Ryan fan and it like
almost Justified my existence because
until then I had like no confidence yeah
I was very like low confidence kind of
person what year was the first season so
you think 2005. oh my God yeah that's my
first YouTube video right there oh yeah
someone like seeing somebody say that
and like
feeling like oh like oh I have a
responsibility now to uphold their
confidence in me you know it was it was
a good feeling but at the same time of
course if you read The Forum and you
like the compliments you're gonna get
affected by the negatives too yeah and
at the time reality TV was a different
Beast yeah and you know negatives were
just as big as positives and then I
started going through the rabbit hole of
like reading about people that didn't
like me and it would just break my heart
and everybody would go through this
um kind of like
up and down thing like all the
contestants because we didn't know yet
no one had ever primed us that like hey
don't read about yourself online because
I wasn't even a thing yeah and then
um we learned the hard way like
everybody had these identity crisis the
uh abilities would go Haywire like you
just wouldn't be able to perform or do
your thing because you would just be
thinking so much about how somebody
hates you some random person that's
weird yeah it was weird because you
couldn't resist looking at it be like
you'd know it's bad for you but no one's
ever written about you anywhere on a
blog or nothing so you're like what are
they saying what are they saying and if
it's bad it's just like destroys you
I do remember uh watching you on the
first season and uh I remember again
we're all ignorant because this is like
the very first time it happened but I
remember thinking it was like there's no
way uh like a hip-hop dancer or a b-boy
is gonna get that far yeah I was just
like there's there's some sort of uh
Unwritten
politics to like the dance yeah yeah
yeah right you know what I mean and
you know uh
it's not untrue no even one sense it is
I think true yeah yeah so so I remember
thinking to myself I'm like Yo dude
how's Ryan gonna like you know do well
on this I think it was true then but
then following That season people would
train specifically for the show yeah
knowing they would have to do Latin
Ballroom all that [__] well that's
exactly what I'm saying we didn't know
you had to do lag and I remember when
your hair was all like combed over you
were in like [__] bell bottom pants
and stuff right plunging v-neck to your
belly button or whatever it was your way
yeah
did this guy either sell out
or not hip-hop or is this amazing I
remember being like whoa like because it
was low-key like if you know people who
pay attention to the scene just straight
up again and we weren't even like friend
friends back then or anything like that
I just remember being like this looks
funny right just you coming out but then
when you did it I was like because they
had the whole pre-interview packages
right right so like you would know that
you were gonna kind of do stuff like
that and it'd be like this is so funny
like look at this b-boy trying to do I
know
yeah and then you come out and you're
like full outfit and you're like
committed and I was like
whoa he's pretty good dude I worked so
freaking hard to get that routine right
oh dude it was it was a it was one of
those yeah Fish Out of Water for sure
Fish Out of Water but like surviving and
it was one of those things where you
were like wait a minute
you don't have to be one way
you can just do multiple things yeah you
know what I'm saying like that was just
yeah simple intro to your bisexuality
yes
and then when you was on the chopping
block and you had to [__] do your
freestyle yeah wow you remember this
song too poison of course man like that
I think that to me from a fan of Ryan in
the entire career and the length of your
life that I think will it would be a top
three moment in that stuff for sure
because what it said yeah what it said
in that moment it's like you were on the
chopping block I think that's the
context yeah yeah yeah yeah you're about
to be cut basically so save your life no
yeah you don't see people fight for
their lives through dance you don't
that's true yeah
it's not a battle it's like uh right if
he doesn't pull something out of his ass
right now he's going home it's like you
have to you have to kill it off yeah and
then you did something that you just
never really did before like I never
seen that headstand like that before you
know I mean I saw a back head spring
like flip thing yeah tap your head in
the moment did I tell you how I first
did that the very very first one
mentioned again it was at all Cal
oh yeah yeah because I was trying to go
all the way over but I messed up because
I was trying to impress freaking Cheryl
like I really wanted to date this girl
who didn't want to date me and uh she
was like in the audience and I was like
oh I have a solo coming up I gotta make
it the best one of my life and it's at
Union Station where it's like basically
100 year old tile so it's like the
hardest surface you could ask for and
then um I wanted to just do it where I
bounce on my head and stand up and look
all cool and I was gonna look at her but
then I slipped and I landed straight on
my head and just went and then I made
eye contact with her anyway upside down
and then I remembered after that show at
all Cal people were coming up and going
yo dude that was tight never seen that
before how did you think of that and I
was like ah you know just in the lab you
know just like working on it you know I
tried to like play it off like that's
something I had in the pocket meanwhile
you had a concussion yeah meanwhile I
was like what the hell how do I do that
again how do I replicate it dude yeah
insane and you could tell you could tell
when it's like when you watch somebody
do something in a battle and like let's
say they like you know they they do 90s
or 2000s but they did like two extra
spins and they normally yeah yeah yeah
and they get up with the fire like like
the Holy Ghost is in them that was like
your energy you hit this thing yeah and
you're like there for a second yeah and
then you get up whoa right because like
until then like tons of dudes were
already like showing it where they would
just go bang uh there's maybe like a
maybe one or two people that I
remembered being able to to stick it but
not that long like nobody like it like a
freaking location pin and that was you
know that was always and again I love I
love that you know I do geography
because at the end of the day like
straight up choreographers get paid the
most in the entire Dance World yeah say
that for real once I recognize that I
was like this is where I'm going but
when I first started dance my first
thing that I was doing was was breaking
that was your very first very first
thing is it's what my first love for
dance so so Mike you and Mike battling
at school made you want to be a b-boy
dude I don't know man uh I was again I
had never danced a formally or like
officially so I was like one and I was
like [__] walking and whatever you know
what I mean little bits here and there
yeah I saw things I was trying to be
Michael when I battle Mike but it wasn't
until
we become freshmen
um
I think it was uh cadc auditions are at
the beginning of the year and cabba
auditions are like later on like in
January at the fiscal year or whatever
and uh Mike is about to like audition
for cadc so I was like oh maybe I should
try this I've never really done [__]
like Mike was gonna audition for DC he
went to auditions right and then I think
it was like people like Ben Ben Chung
was like nah dude come I just for Kaaba
wow so Mike's obviously like oh okay so
yeah because it's Ben like who's not
gonna does an audition for DC but
obviously I never learned this [__]
before either even though I went to
auditions with him like the learning of
it
um so I don't audition because I've
never done this and the only free Club
was UCI b-boy Club oh yeah you didn't
have to audition you just go to the arc
the uh anteater Recreation Center
once a week and then you just session
and people will teach you and it's just
like open space yeah so I would go there
with Victor I didn't have to audition
for anything I didn't have to be good at
anything I could just learn so I started
b-boying first and you know for all the
wrong reasons just trying to like look
hot for girls type stuff like you know
no Foundation let's go right to
windmills right yeah let's spit like
Ken's Journey right now right Ken yeah
yeah where's your foundation right now
but he's posting his like continuous
windmills every year right because it's
like the most fun part it is because
that's what b-boy gives you when you
like stick a freeze that trumps dude
every other feeling yeah yeah you know
what I mean and like that's why
I don't know I still love it I still
love watching I still love you being a
part of it in some way damn that's cool
I didn't know that was your first thing
that you wanted to do yeah it was my
first and then I was uh I got injured
all the time
because I was weak and not good and then
I remember I remember you being you were
pretty skinny back then thank you like
uh but not like you were like lanky
Skitty which everybody calls me fat but
yes I was like you scared well the only
time I remember you gaining weight was
after you quit dance
you you had you had a weird like so from
my side
I remember you had this like moment
where word around the house I lived in
was that Anthony doesn't dance now and
he got a man's job and he's like yeah
sales yeah and then that's when I
remember you were coming over and then
you just looked so different like you
just looked sad say different again in a
different word three letter words starts
with f ends with an a
you uh you came by I just remember you
looked so like your spirit was gone and
I was like hey man how's the job going
and you were like
no I mean that's like the least of the
of the change the the major thing was
you're you're you were just so like gone
like your face was just like I was like
hey how's your job and you're like no I
don't you like didn't want to talk about
it this is the depressing moment where
I'm gonna ask Chad to pour me a shot
but think about this like the thing that
always trips me out which I always want
to credit you for is that like imagine
if you never stopped that path
there would be like no none of that like
the fact that you came out of that I
mean you could have become like wildly
successful in sales that would be fine
but that is my biggest regret what not
being successful in sales yeah my
biggest regret is is coming back to
dance no stupid no for sure that was
crazy
um because I actually physically saw
that fork in the road which is crazy to
me because you know people might you
might tell your story somewhere and then
people would just imagine I should tell
that story right now actually I've never
really talked about that entire Journey
yeah I'm gonna take a shot it's wild
because do it
you almost had a completely different
life
yeah so um
man is uh this is such a weird time in
my life I just graduated
um
Mike was you know uh doing his whole cab
of modern post ABDC life where it was
just like this conundrum of
um constantly traveling yeah constantly
living it up he was living in a big time
yeah he was huge and then we were on our
way we were about to do ABDC yeah and I
was nowhere near like that World
um and I you know when I graduated I
remember one of the first places I
applied to
um ended up being one of these sales
jobs right and it was one of those
business to business ones where like
people in suits they walk around and
they just like they solicit they like
walk into stores and sell ship they're
selling like anything they're selling
stuff from baseball tickets to coupon
books to Clippers tickets so your your
job is to sell to stores yeah so like
they put together this back in the day
again you know what's funny is I had a
complete misunderstanding somebody had
said at the time that you were
door-to-door selling books
that's as good as it gets yeah that was
like I understand what it was that was
like kind of like the basis of it oh
like you would go business it was
business a bit because it like the the
maybe the a decade right before that
like the 90s right people would go door
to door yeah residential right and then
you know suddenly you remember when
people would [__] like knock on your
residential door and they'd have like
like the backs of car seats or like
different toys yeah yeah that doesn't
happen no more yeah exactly it doesn't
happen anymore because people probably
like die now
um
but it's not worth your life yeah but
that evolved and then it became like
people put on suits they got like better
deals with better clients okay and so we
got into a realm where like we were
walking around a season we were working
with like the Dodgers or working with
like the Oakland A's like every almost
major sports team uh around the nation
because the whole concept is especially
if you want like a top tier sports team
but like you just had a huge stadium
with a lot of seats yeah they would have
excess seats so then it would make more
sense for like those organizations to
give away those free seats if they
weren't selling them anyway in order to
make sales off the concessions make
sales off of parking make sales off of
what the heads being in there yeah
otherwise you just have an empty seat so
they would constantly give us these free
coupon seats and then we would go
selling those coupons in a bundle at a
discounted package and people who are
familiar especially like you know we're
in like Southern California when we were
pushing Dodgers tickets like all the
Hispanics out here they knew we would
come around so anytime you walked into
the right type of Shop people like you
guys are the Dodgers guys come over here
so it was okay also for for guys that
were not afraid to go to different
businesses like guys like me
you could do really well and I was so
you were not afraid you didn't have a
shyness or like a inhibition I'm more
one of those guys I'm like what the [__]
are you doing you know like this is
stupid like give me that [__] I'll just
do it you know I could see that you were
good at just cold talking to people yeah
I'm just gonna like it's like this is
the pitch okay cool like I'm not about
this but let me see if I can do it and
then I'll do it and I'll be like I could
do it and I'll be like doing it better
than half the guys in the office and I'm
like and you're younger you're like the
Young Buck yeah you know what I mean and
I'm like this isn't what I want to be or
where I want to you know go with things
but I'm good at it and I was just like
making money for the first time truly
yeah you know what I mean and I was like
okay and then I got into the point where
I was just also at that point in the um
in that industry scope where it started
evolving in general so we I was part of
the um the test team where we wouldn't
walk around business business we would
go into places like Sam's Club or Costco
and we'd have a booth there and we would
sell different cards at a booth and we
would do even more sales because this
now people aren't being solicited to now
they're going to a place where they're
already looking to be you know solicited
or sold something yeah yeah yeah so it
was a more appropriate environment so we
would suddenly 10x sales at a person who
was walking in the streets would do oh
that's dope okay so then I was on this
team where I would constantly be like
the Innovative team that would push new
initiatives with the company the the
major company Across the Nation I'll be
flown out to like Texas for convention
so no way
it started going really really well
right and then um
basically got to a point where uh in our
branch in like in Orange County and like
Santa Ana or whatever or Anaheim
um the assistant manager there got
pushed up to a manager position so she
opened an office in in Riverside that's
when I moved to Riverside because I was
under her team so I go out and I work
under her team and I became the
assistant manager and I started running
the entire office out there and the
thing is she was like super lazy and
[__] and she was also [__] the
[__] old manager for Anaheim anyway
so it was like they're in concludes in a
different way which was cool but like
she was a little lazy so I'm gonna keep
it real
um and I basically ran like the whole
Riverside office right so then there was
a point that's how you get promoted man
you start yeah doing someone else's job
yeah so then there was a point where
obviously I was doing well so even the
upper is there like it's time for him to
get promoted because that's the whole
point you join not to do those sales you
join almost like a 2x2.net kind of
marketing uh kind of client yeah yeah
you do it because when you get to a
different position all the cronies under
you who are doing the sales you're
getting a portion of those profits you
know what I'm saying so like I was
working for about a year and a half to
get into this place and I was killing it
and I was getting to this place and I'm
running the office basically in
Riverside I'm doing hiring firing I'm
doing like morning meetings uh and I
didn't know you got up to that level I
was I was so far in that level that it
was time for me to get promoted to
manager myself so we were opening my
office in Arizona I was gonna move you
were gonna leave the stage I had a going
away party they got me a cake I
literally was getting promoted and and
on Blue Black Ops on the Black Ops which
was the first performance of kinjaz ever
was my going away performance I didn't
even know that so that whole thing came
together because I was quitting dance
formally like leaving the scene wow and
I hit a mic and I'm like yo Mike dude
like I'm I'm gonna move to Arizona for
this job and he already knew all this
stuff and I was like so I want to do one
last dance thing so that show might not
have even been close to what it ended up
being had you not been no about to leave
everything was very like last two raw
kind of like attitude that's why when we
got there like in our show if you watch
this first show of Ken just like I love
that show we're literally we're drinking
on stage with all of our College roomies
that you lived with yeah yeah I was
about getting people to just come out
and just have a good time together
um we were dancing to because I got high
and we even asked Jason Parker like can
we smoke weed on stage and he's like
dude that's too far that's a fire hazard
so that's why we just danced Because I
Got High we were like jacking off in
that routine you know what I mean like
we're doing everything as if it's a last
hurray yeah um because that was me
hanging up my shoes wow I hit up Mike
too when I asked him I was like yo you
know it's my last dance thing like will
you do it he like he was killing it he
was booking everything he was like
traveling there he was gone dude but he
was like all right for that month of
January as you were not ready for it
he's like I won't do any gigs
yeah that's a big thing to do because
business was never booming as hard as it
was that exactly so so that was for real
like a going away thing yeah and then uh
that was in January like January 28th or
January 31st 2010 and we finish that
thing we gotta we get a standing
elevation obviously that shows like one
of the I that's top one loved ones in my
life hands down it doesn't matter
anything else comes in life that's still
number one
um and then that week
I go back into Riverside I go back to my
job I'm getting ready this is like maybe
like my last month in that office I'm
supposed to I'm already looking for uh
Apartments I found an apartment on
Arizona the whole thing right
that week it was a Thursday
and I for some reason I should have saw
this coming but maybe I was just already
too like like in the momentum of like
I'm moving forward you know this is like
where I'm gonna go with [__]
um
that week on Thursday for whatever
[__] reason uh the office and the
team wasn't ready for me to leave so
they had to hold me back
right her my man is getting postponed or
hold you back like you cannot be
promoted both oh both it was just an
indefinite like oh like uh you know
everything is a boner killer basically
basically yeah but what it really came
down to again like I said just a little
ago I was basically running that office
so what really would happen is if I
would leave just like in Anaheim when my
my manager got promoted right when she
got promoted her whole team including
myself we all left there and you go with
your team the people you bring in or
you're training either your team right
so you leave with your team at that
point she was no longer working and
going the field because I was doing
everything yeah so she didn't really
have a team
which meant that like if I were to move
to Arizona I would be taking the hole so
she would lose everyone under her too
exactly so she would literally noticed
up exactly so that's why her and again
she was like in a relationship they
prevented you the person who was above
her that she came from that you know our
team team leader yeah so then again
being blocked out basically yeah yeah
you know what I mean and that morning
when we got held back I still kept my
cool with it and I still did the morning
meeting and stuff but my main assistant
manager my assistant yeah who I brought
in was my number one guy right-hand man
his name is Derek
we live together in Riverside we moved
from Anaheim and lived together we like
started this journey and you know all
these promises of like growth and stuff
and we got held back again that day we
quit we just walked out he just called
left yeah just cold left we're like you
know after this like it's over and we
just left it and I remember driving home
from that Riverside office and I
remember I called my sister uh because I
didn't know I didn't know who else to
hit up and I remember just crying on the
phone as if I had like failed something
because there was no plan there was no
there's no severance there's no two
weeks no there's no other career change
yeah right it was just like a feeling of
being held back failing or losing
something you know what I mean yeah but
I think that in combination with the
emotions that I had four days prior at
Vibe where I had the greatest Peak and
experience and emotion ever in the
history of my entire dance relationship
yeah yeah and I was leaving that
I was like let me go deny this thing
that brought me absolute happiness let
me just walk away and put my hang my
shoes up even though it brought me so
much identity and confidence and joy and
belonging yeah let me hang that up let
me go do something that I absolutely
hate
just because I'm decent at it get held
back you know what I mean uh and then
just I remember like hitting her up and
she was she was like it's okay you know
what I mean because I I thought all the
other stupid Asian boy pressures you
know or anybody in general it's like I
failed it's been like two years since
College I got nothing for myself I don't
have much saved up I'm living in
Riverside and I gotta just move back
home like where I don't have anywhere at
home to go I gotta go to my parents you
know I mean everything just felt like
I'm sure too at this time like jumping
back into dance full-time seemed
completely like unattainable wasn't
wasn't even in the books actually I
think
um because everything was moving so fast
and this was 200 like nine yeah for me
um so then I ended up getting uh I ended
up getting a job from one of my best
friends Sean who was running uh flow
route which was an internet telephony
company kind of like Vonage back in the
day using like voice over IP internet
for phone calls so he knows my situation
he just hooks me up with a job of course
I'm not trained of course I'm not saying
it hooks me up with a job good friend
man and he trains me I like work there
for like only a month or something like
that and then I get recruited by my boy
alex at collusive clothing company right
right so I get recruited to do because
he's like I heard you did sales he's
like and I was like yeah pretty good at
sales he's like I need somebody to come
do sales I ended up transitioning over
there and then doing sales and marketing
but that's how I got back connected to
the dance world because collusive was so
linked into dance yeah collusive is like
the Zeitgeist of dance apparel like
dance team fashion you can see that
entire era that collusive had it's like
you know whole on the entire dancer your
branding everywhere every event every
whatever right and so that's what got me
back into the dance realm because I
ended up being the point of marketing
and then seeding out all this clothing
that's very smart that you were the one
doing that because you already have the
trust of like all of the dance there was
this hilarious moment actually
um because I ended up started to do a
lot of the marketing
um and Kyle Deneen was also doing at
that time when I first came in
um but there was one funny mess up I
remember that happened because it was
ABDC season
five during that era right and uh
um are the collusive art director at the
time who's doing a lot of the designs
was Josh eulip who's Brother of um
Hazmat has been yeah exactly right so
uh oh no the new con is the brother of
Josh right Hazmat so then uh Josh is on
ABDC right and type 5-0 as high five oh
and they're competing with periodics and
then well way better than periodics yeah
what had happened is we had brought a
box of cluesome merch uh-huh for high
five oh
excuse me in some sort of confusion
periodics thought the box was for them
so the whole rest of the season four
addicts has all this exclusive gear that
was not ever meant for that but they got
it I didn't know that and so they're
just hella rapid and we had to get a and
again this is before I was doing all the
marketing and stuff like that too so but
that's kind of a great mistake because
they end up being the winners right yeah
I know it's wonderful kid you know what
I'm talking about do you know this story
you just Jack the whole box
how we got the shirts but we did oh man
but that was just literally how far yeah
one Colusa was in the dance world and
then two like like ironically after all
that sales and stuff like that I come
back and now I'm in this position
because I'm like I know people or
whatever you know what I'm saying so
just just it wasn't even about coming
back to dance for me yeah I just started
being surrounded by it again through
life and then it wasn't until 2011 when
I got laid off but not because like the
company there's a lot of business
complex sometimes and for the sake of
the company everything was amicable but
I did have to get laid off in order for
things to like not bring a certain type
of liability to me
um but
I remember it's 2011 uh the time in
which I got laid off was also the time
in which me and my longtime girlfriend
at that time broke up and I was living
with her in Hollywood you know
um and then so I'm laid off jobless
heartbroken from like who I thought I
was gonna marry and then had to like
move out of that apartment so I moved
back home important part time that is
what you call a high value man
I was [__] miserable I was like this
is like my lowest probably Point ever
you know what I'm saying in my entire
life because you just felt so broken you
know
multiple years after graduating college
it's crazy that I'm rapidly passing you
throughout this whole time and I don't
even know that you're that like busted
dude I didn't know you're that much of
an introvert nerd when you were living
yeah but um I remember uh and this is
the time where back then there was not
even LinkedIn back then so if you wanted
to apply for jobs and stuff like that
you were going to things like
monster.com or what you know what I'm
talking about like like yeah literally
you're looking for jobs you have to
submit resumes all the time yeah and
there was something it's almost like a
casting site yeah it was there was
something so demoralizing for me
personally like trying to re-put my
resume together you know what I'm saying
yeah like years after you graduate and
just feeling like and yeah maybe this I
also have my closest friends around me
at that time people like Victor people
like Mike yeah who were excelling at
things in ways that that that industry
had never seen before yeah and chasing
passions in a career that like was so oh
yeah people were making it happen yeah
they were making it happen so I felt so
inadequate yeah you know what I'm saying
I felt really like there was a lot of
things that maybe I didn't ever really
give myself a chance to process but
emotionally for real I was like low
right so I remember thinking to myself
there were these periods of times where
I put hours into like
so depressing to sit there and just
submit your [__] resume yeah read
this job listing submit read this and
you're just doing that like fishing but
like shittier
um there were even a couple times I went
on interviews for different places and I
do do fully remember one time I sat in
an interview and you know standard
typical interview questions like you
know why do you want to like work here
and I froze because it was so hard for
me to lie at that point in sales I was
it's like a really bad movie you're like
you know what I don't want to work here
that was my heart my heart was like cats
out of the room don't want to work here
so instead I remember looking I I freeze
I was just looking at this lady because
my heart wanted to just be like I don't
want to but I know I'm supposed to say
something else but I can't bring myself
to say it and now this is getting
awkward it was just [__] weird you
know what I mean but that's that was
just a just a huge that's the moment
yeah and so I go home failed again and
I'm doing my daily routine I'm like I
have to you know here's my hustle I have
to look up different job listings and I
remember when I would be so at the
lowest point and hating that the only
thing that gave me
some sort of Salvation was freestyling
was just dancing so I was like I'm gonna
[__] not do this right now and I'll
play some music and get down and for me
A lot of it was also choreographing
right because for some like I just felt
like if I choreograph me putting
sequences together
like no one could judge that and take
that away from me it was like the only
thing I had yeah you know what I'm
saying like no matter how much somebody
judges my resume no matter if I get laid
off because I wasn't good enough here if
I didn't do a good job here it also
never needs to be up for judgment
exactly it was just the only thing that
I could create and then like hold on to
yeah right so like I would just suddenly
start pouring hours into that and I
would have these routines but I'll be
broke so I would slowly hit up random
people in between my like looking for
like jobs I would hit up random people
but hey I um
I'm still around I still exist yeah like
come teach at your studio we're gonna do
something and I remember getting like 20
bucks for a workshop and thinking like
yes I can like buy like Boba this week
you know what I mean like I can do
something I remember when I got an
offered a job in Culver City's your
neighborhood Studio it was 20 bucks per
class and it was once a week and I would
drive from Buena Park to Culver City
which is like the gas money alone is
like the whole thing yeah but I was like
if I do this I can make 80 bucks a month
I can pay for my cell phone what are so
just for perspective what's the highest
you've been paid for a workshop at for
the same amount of time the highest
you've been paid like ever in life
just to scale for people what 20 bucks
is in comparison to this maybe like
three thousand dollars Jesus Christ for
like a like a 90 minute Workshop jeez
3000 versus 20 bucks yeah for the same
amount of time it's just a it's a
totally different scale you know what I
mean yeah but at that time right twenty
dollars was everything to me and I think
that's that's more important right the
mentality of it you know even just in
the hopes that that might lead to
another 20 bucks next week and that's
all it was and there was Word of Mouth
people would be like yo Anthony's still
dancing apparently
um but that's all I had I that that's
you know and I remember that's a great
flyer for your Workshop by the way
Anthony's still dancing apparently
twenty dollars but I do remember when I
made maybe like a hundred bucks in like
a two week period because of a
difference yeah I was like yeah I was
like holy [__] I'm like maybe there's a
maybe there's a chance and my one of my
most pivotal pivotal conversations of
all time for my dance career was when I
looked at Mike's song and I asked him
and I was like yo man like honest tell
me the homie like do you think that I
can like if I tried to do this dance
thing because again like this was a very
first era in which people started doing
you know what I mean it wasn't yeah yeah
yeah it was just a new thing and I was
like I was looking at myself there's
nobody to learn from there's no failures
to learn from it's just this and Mike
was killing it you know he was killing
like yeah I was like Yo dude like
do you think I could do this and without
hesitation he's like yeah
I was like
and that's not like homie to homie
that's like he's being real yeah and
then he looked at me he's like dude you
know that you've already gotten more
dance opportunities in life than so many
people who like moved from other
countries to La who try that's a good
place their entire goal and that's still
the case for for a lot of people totally
that's true yeah
I was like oh [__] that's a good point
yeah and then the most the second most
important question I ask you know I'm
like will you help me and he's like yeah
no how did he help you
number one I think just having somebody
say that they would help you is is like
so he never did anything he never did it
he just said [__]
um one of the my first time truly
traveling internationally for dance was
when he brought me as an assistant to
Croatia he didn't need to whoa he would
have made more money if he didn't he'd
already been going out to countries by
himself but definitely he this was his
first time going with his promoter so
there was a comfort in having a friend
because like yeah at the same time this
was also an era where like you didn't
know who the wrong promoters were you
didn't know and everybody was trying to
be a promoter exactly out of nothing and
people were getting left in the dust out
there too people were getting [__]
conned or like jacked and bad jobs here
you know so anytime somebody was working
with like a new promoter in that area
era there was something to being like
you know bring my bring my manager with
me bring my assistant with me or
something you know just in case the
worst happens you know so he he was
willing to bring me I was super chubby
we got photos from this time
um but it brings me out to Croatia and
assisting him and I got this taste
imagine he's like all right y'all want
to see what it looks like if you're fat
all right go ahead Anthony
that's all he brought you for
yeah I would have still done
um but that was like you know when you
give somebody a taste yeah and I'm not
I'm a real taste you know what I'm
talking about yeah you're in another
country people save up their like
Croatia yeah they save up forever to try
and be able to travel somewhere I'm
there on somebody else's dying yeah an
opportunity and name at that point for
me personally and I just get to
experience it and do what a little bit
of dancing you know what I mean you go
to you go on a trip like that you're
there for like four days but you teach
what maybe two three classes an hour and
a half per class you're really actually
working like four to five hours
yeah total total work you know what I'm
saying and the rest is like
what vacation for you for a bit you know
sit on a panel and do a q a like oh yeah
you're talking about like all the free
and easy days yeah it's just like
because they also want you to have a
good experience which is cool yeah and
then it's like you're making the same
amount of money in literally a weekend
that I was making in two weeks to a
month oh yeah yeah doing what you love
so I think once you get first-hand
experience because remember those first
few years too like I'm I'm sure for you
as well when you're traveling teaching
performing whatever it was you were
doing weren't people still perplexed
like so you get to go to this country
and just dance oh yeah and it's like and
so they
they pay for your flight yeah and they
pay for your hotel all of it seems so
weird and they pay for your food and you
get I was also asking myself that you
know what I'm saying like it was such a
weird like process to catch every time
you go you're like what's the catchy
exactly what's gonna happen that was
just what it was people literally
desired what you had to give them and
they would pay you top dollar for it and
like the second I got that actual taste
to note was real
you know it was like it was like me
joining that sales job once I saw
somebody else do this I didn't give a
[__] what it was I was on the first team
to push makeup because I because I had
so much ego that I was like [__]
nobody else is gonna do it I'll do it
and I'll do it with everybody in this
office so I was there was a point where
I was going business to business selling
makeup just to prove a point to my team
what was your what was your opening line
tired of looking ugly I was like damn
you're [__] fine you want to look
fine I have no idea what it was but you
know it's just like it was just that
kind of like mentality and again for me
that attitude that I had and then I saw
somebody do it yeah yeah then I knew it
was attainable right and like that
changed everything I mean that's
probably like 90 of it to me is just
seeing how it can be done yeah yeah yeah
and you know like I think we were
privileged to live in that era where it
wasn't done before us so we got maybe a
bunch of first time the ignorance was a
major privilege but we just went head
first into everything without any doubts
or like you just did it yeah I was I was
I was teaching a workshop at UCLA like
this past weekend right and it was a q a
after and then one of the questions you
know super I remember these questions
all the time being a kid too and one of
the questions like how do you like find
your own style you know what I mean
and uh again there's no like
100 correct right answer to this I think
everybody has their own answer right but
I remember having to think about it and
being like you know um the time in which
I grew up uh learn and dance and stuff
like we didn't have YouTube IG Tick Tock
anything like that right there was
nothing in abundance they're only like
the minuscule moments that you got
something by going to like a jam or
going to like a club right asking like
an OG that you maybe saw in one clip
through like Napster or something like
that they give you one tip and that's it
and then yeah three months yeah you're
living on that tip yeah but I was like
but there was something about that time
for all of us as creators because if you
didn't get influenced by the
overabundance of content or you weren't
taking a bunch of class all you were
doing was doing the things that you had
and then trying to evolve that and it
would eventually kind of Harden
something about you right right you know
what I'm saying and I like to say this
still like during that era there's way
less dancers but way more artists and
creators and today everybody knows how
to dance but like there's very very few
innovators in the space yeah yeah
because everything is a natural kind of
like regurgitation of everything that
has been created or like they've put
into their body or whatever it seems
like it's so hard to be an innovator
because you have such an overload of
data back in the day some people
innovated things just because they
didn't know it already existed exactly
and they took a road and they just kept
going because they didn't know someone
else was taking that same road and then
they met in the middle and went oh you
do that too and they're both proficient
in different like ways but now it's like
you could stop yourself every turn just
going Awesome's doing that already yeah
I mean it's kind of like I was never in
dance classes like my first for real
like kind of foray going into dance
classes was when I was already getting
invited to dance camps to teach and I
felt like a jerk for being on that
lineup and then like we're already there
like why would I not take this person's
class who just took mine you know what
I'm saying like other choreographers
taking each other's classes stuck in
Sweden right now and there's nothing to
do because it's snowing outside yeah but
be at these workshops like why would I
not just jump in this person's class
even if I'm gonna look like a fool but
if I'm gonna look like full I might as
well do it like across the world and
back in my own tour that's true you know
what I'm saying so like that was me
finally going into dance classes because
you just did your own thing you know
what I'm saying you did it long enough
until you got good at something and you
bunked up with people who kind of did
similar stuff yeah period in the so in
the future like skipping over a little
bit when you started coming to JK as uh
not JK news but when you started doing
skits and stuff yeah and then you ended
up on the news did you ever want to like
be a host on JK news did you ever think
like oh my God this is somewhere I want
to be long term never never I was um not
because it wasn't cool
it was like
what's it like it's like um because your
first skit with them was what 2 000 like
like 12. dang yeah yeah it was after the
six Six Tour and there was like that
following year 2012. and that's a Yakuza
thing was that the First skit No that's
all that was like the the third or
fourth or something oh okay yeah I did I
did random stuff with them I did I was
in a skit I did a couple a few skits
with Lawrence Cal they always made a
super gay in it
someone's got to be gay right
um I did a skit with them in 2009 or 10.
something like that it was like maybe it
was 11. but it was a I think they took
it off because it I think it got some
Flack it was like it was a skit about
suicide and how you like you like take a
pill and it makes you laugh and then die
and then um yeah it was like me and
Steve were in it I think and Fang and
then and then I remember meeting them
that day and I think I might have even
met you that day
yeah
yeah it was it was uh that era was
really really just fun because I feel
like I was already doing things on
YouTube I was putting myself out on
YouTube and stuff and like when people
like stumble upon my my choreography or
whatever and they don't hear me talk or
don't know anything about me
like my dance choices are very uh I
guess for for lack of better terms or
how would you describe my dance
choreography like just blatantly just
looking at my dance team you didn't know
anything about me you're just like
looking at my style of movement and
choices I would say very interesting
details in the choices and the songs are
always usually like what like my
favorite YouTuber a little yeah my
favorite thing about your choreo is that
you choose to do something that I think
from a dancer's perspective is the least
expected thing on small moments oh yeah
yeah like rather like because my [__]
idiot brain always wants to do
everything big and then once I saw your
guys's stuff how you put a lot of focus
on these like little pictures I I can't
think that way so I appreciate it yeah
so like that I think is very
it's uh very contradictory to like my
natural personality you know what I mean
like sometimes like when people meet me
they would never expect that my
personality the way I speak is the way
that like that creator of moves because
like you know it's like more subtle it's
more like yeah you know um ethereal a
little more deep and like quiet and
reserved right yeah sometimes it's like
really just soft spoken stuff right so
like that's my way to express myself you
know what I mean in just that way ways
that I don't have regular words to so
when I was in JK film stuff and I was
already on YouTube in different ways I
was even doing Wong Fu stuff from time
to time yeah
I just felt so blessed to have a
different Outlet publicly so to speak to
like have fun yeah yeah in front of the
camera then my normal [__] because my
normal [__] again I naturally just
choreographed like that or whatever you
know
um and then JK films comes around and
then suddenly we're just doing these
skits and they're like hey we need some
gay guys what are you doing Friday it's
funny because I give him [__] for it but
obviously of course they're not riding
like hella gay scripts or anything like
that because like they're like they're
like so anti-gated they're like
homophobes for a little bit at that time
there's such cases right which of course
it's more so because dancers are so in
tune like we're we're constantly like it
right
doing stuff all the times and it's it's
especially for dudes in like
predominantly guy groups it's like of
course we're gonna just be comfortable
so sure when me and Lawrence are coming
on a set for them they're probably
thinking like this was a hell of gay one
really we're just like super comfortable
it's like being an all-boy summer camp
for like Perpetual years yeah but like
that [__] was just so fun and when news
came around and we just sit there and
talk the funny thing is that I feel like
when I first came on the news everyone's
just such a [__] comedian was that
like 2000 when was it 2012 2013. I
remember when I first saw you on on JK
news I used to watch JK news a lot yeah
yeah like since they started it like the
debut of it and then I saw you on there
and I was like dude that's [__] tight
I thought you were really good oh yeah
so I was like oh he's so cool
you know what's funny I feel like when I
was a guest versus now being a host yeah
it's very very opposite experience very
opposite not just the work that I do but
even just the personality that I have
yeah because back then
I was so rarely on yeah that when I came
on I feel like it was like uh
I don't know it's it's not a matter of
like being yourself or not but like my
voice was the most um uh grounded in the
room it wasn't like jokes because you
know I didn't know I was just coming on
I was just literally speaking my mind on
a topic yeah yeah yeah you know what I'm
saying but then once you become a
regular and stuff like that uh
uh you're not always trying to get your
point across about sure yeah it's not so
important yeah you know what I mean you
just talk about whatever right and then
like it was like I was I was regular for
like this blip of a second before
becoming a host just because of the time
of that yeah yeah I mean I remember
distinctly like the first time I came on
as a guest I I misunderstood like I was
so worried that I wouldn't have anything
good to say or like there's some
episodes I didn't like one episode they
did I think one of the first ones ever
when I came on here they were like all
right so we're going to talk about Game
of Thrones in the recent episode I was
like I've never seen one episode of Game
of Thrones I spent the whole episode
just going
yeah and you think about it too right
yeah when you're like a first I remember
like yeah you're like third time I'm so
mental yeah I remember my because the
first couple times I would be a guest I
remember coming home and just being like
yo I think I did a good job I was like
talking yeah I just want to contribute
yeah at the other day it's like a big
YouTube channel and you don't want to
interrupt anybody too because you don't
understand that like the pockets you're
just kind of like and then I do remember
it was like my third time or something
coming on and like there would just be a
couple articles that were like sometimes
you just don't know what to say or you
don't have something to say the flow is
just going a certain way right and
you're like whoa and you don't know that
that's okay either yeah it's like 15
minutes went by I didn't say anything I
did a bad job
there's a totally different Dynamic yeah
yeah when you're just like a guest and
it's all in here like it really is
totally yeah it's funny but then like
you know being a regular and then like
also also when you're in the guest seat
which of course we're still there
because yeah but when you're sitting at
that table it's like the energy of the
room goes together everybody sitting on
the side is looking that's like when you
told Jason Cheney like hey sit on that
side and it'll feel way different right
it's completely different It's So
Different yeah it's like it is it just
feels more relaxing and stuff like that
but it is it is refreshing now yeah to
be on the other side and you know
sometimes because guests will say even
Jason Cheney said that one time recently
when when they don't kind of contribute
and they're like oh look I don't know I
I didn't was that okay yeah yeah you
know what I mean you're like dude it's
okay I forget that people will still be
thinking that because you thought that
yeah yeah yeah everybody yeah always but
it's it is you know like especially now
like Geo had mentioned it too like the
flow is so especially the careful boys
area attitude it's very natural we have
a pocket now because we I think we went
through a lot of ups and downs together
and like testing certain things and hell
yes being able to take like trips and
and just kind of like spend some time
developing some sort of chemistry right
you know specific quickly and even our
initiatives to like requests like uh
sessions where there are no guests
sometimes yeah yeah straight up you just
be like hey just to build the dynamic
yeah it's kind of good to not have like
new energy all the time and just right
because you have to accommodate yeah
yeah and like now you know we've gotten
our our energy to a certain place with
the Attitude Era and the careful boys
that even Geo comes in she's like I
don't even want to disrupt that I know I
was like I can't believe Jesus saying
that's crazy you know what I'm saying
because she is technically the dynamic
yeah that's the yeah but the framework I
find a sense of um
I would totally say Pride because I feel
like we put in energy we you know when
you put work you actually try yeah for
things happen you know yeah those are
like eight to ten hours of [__] you know
you've got a [__] podcast trying to
go on right now because we're like
putting in energy yeah yeah and that's a
cool thing when you come in as a guest
like you you want to put in your
personal energy in hopes that you're
doing you're doing a good job right and
I think now just like the rest I can
feel it from YouTube just the
responsibility even as hosts knowing
that we're a formal part of this team
and this family yeah we want to try
really hard it's not even trying hard
for ourselves anymore we just want the
the whole thing to work and the Legacy
like to uphold it it's been around so
freaking long and we've just been a part
of it in some way even if we're like
fractions at a time like we've been a
part of this journey for over a decade
yeah like you've shown up yeah like that
one there's that one time you and Steve
were arguing about who's been here in
the locket
so like just for context a lot of people
don't understand that like making fun of
Anthony the reason it's funny is because
he's so cool everywhere freaking else
that you should have at least one place
where you get to play the other role
like you can't be cool everywhere
[Laughter]
it's like that's to me that's why it's
funny is because it's ironic it's like
Channing Tatum in 21 Jump Street where
everyone's ripping on him it's like and
then he's playing that roll up because
it's like he's so sexy and he's
obviously so sexy and he's like trying
to be nerdy because he's sexy and cool
you don't find yourself obviously sexy
and cool shut the [__] up we're not even
talking about this anymore there's way
better things to talk about no but like
I think it's a fun thing to um like
Steve loves to play up on on uh comments
he when people go oh man they're beefing
like they don't like each other Steve
will always agree with them in comments
I don't know if you've ever seen it of
course but his his next comment will be
like yeah I hate that guy no I don't
hate that guy I just hate all damn he
doesn't come on to social media unless
he's [__] talking about like a high
from like yeah or something like that
and trying to [__] rub it in people's
faces or to talk [__] on me like
literally his only time he comes out of
the social media cave
like the very first time we were all in
Vegas we were filming that skit and like
without being scripted or all he walks
out and dumps all the Kindle noodles
into a trash can
I was like what is this would I have
thought that that was going to propel
this like new brand identity for me on
this [__] show like no you're his
favorite straight man as he likes to put
it so dumb I know but that's like
something I remember thinking oh that's
pretty funny when I came in and I
noticed like that you were getting
dumped on I was like oh that's kind of
funny because it is ironic and then I
remembered I was looking for old videos
and I went back several clips and I
found like an old old video where you
were a guest and they were still doing
that to you oh like that's where it
started it was basically the first time
um this is this is the the [__]
Infamous clip by the way I think the
topic is about uh it was like about like
fans right and like everybody's talking
about how like you know fans run them on
the street like fan etiquette sometimes
yeah can we take a photo and just being
awkward or whatever and then I'm like
I'm like fine it's probably one of those
times where I'm like oh I think I have a
story to contribute to oh yeah I'm
talking about like my situation where
like one time right over here on Garvey
like somebody like comes out blah blah
and then bar out of noise like but you
guys didn't even win though right and
it's like it was for sure funny but
David still like he's so [__] he's
just so much
he comes at a large quantity yeah
um and he just Johnson runs up the
camera he's like aha like it was the
biggest roast ever right
and it was a good roast but he
definitely magnified it and then from
there it just was on every comment yeah
it was on every new Kendra's YouTube
video every Instagram post every one of
my new posts and stuff like that and it
just like went super far but it went so
far to the point where like fans would
come up and just kind of talk junk to me
but you know again I have a thick enough
skin where it's like okay like I'm
logical and practical like I know where
this came from so I can't be pissed off
about it but at the same time it's like
when it's everywhere you're kind of like
oh yeah we talked about that before
about how like it's funny in the circle
but when people out of context or
outside of it just think like oh here's
Anthony he loves like hearing this type
of [__] let me just go ahead and tell
them [__] hinges yeah at the airport
yeah so people people are randomly you
know what I mean and it's so out of
point it is funny but then when you got
like other crewmates you don't even
being like yo why this person come on
here and be like [__] Kendra's like
who's this and I have to be like no dude
because there are 80 kids
they're not actually hating it's an
inside joke from JK and they're talking
[__] to me you know just having to
explain the context of a joke yeah yeah
that's when it gets a little bit like oh
it's yeah and it's hard that's a joke
that's hard to explain the context
honestly yeah because it's so based on
the moment that like they're not gonna
start laughing because you explained it
like it's not funny still and I'm me but
I'm not [__] every Kinder right so if
another kid just like yeah who the [__]
is this right you know what I mean but
it becomes a stupid thing where I'm just
constantly planning why people are
saying [__] King James that's really
tough yeah yeah and it's like all right
maybe we should just slow the brakes on
this otherwise I'm not gonna do this in
my [__] late 30s you know what I mean
like can everybody chill out yeah it's
bad when it becomes like a bumper
sticker outside of the room like that's
not the intent the tent of it at all but
but you know how it is I mean sometimes
it gets sometimes it gets heated yeah
you know it'll heat up like that it's
like it's such a it's such a funny thing
to just like dunk on that like you'll
try to explain something you'll try to
get into like a topic and seriously say
something but then Steve's like oh
there's a good joke that's gonna come
out of this it's hard to like it's too
tempting yeah so so there's even a
moments you know uh in JK where it's
like the camera's off it's like yo shut
the [__] up you know what I mean and
we'll have like many little arguments
about it because it just goes so far
yeah but it's not because that moment is
so far it's because of what you know is
residually gonna happen right in that
moment somebody says something like
dickish I'm not thinking like man that's
so [__] up I'm hearing that dickages
and being like this is gonna come for
the next 10 months in comments yeah yeah
you know what I mean and that's what
makes it so much more like oh I hope the
fans are idiots also it doesn't context
does it feel like are you tired of it a
little because it's predictable are you
a little bit like because once you hear
it you know it's going to go on for like
I'm only okay I I submit myself I am
[__] a servant to this news platform
that's just kidding news I understand
nobody like I'll I'll throw it out when
I can to again I'm not a comedian I
don't have like comedy in my Ig like
Steve Green comedy it's not my [__]
thing you know but um
but like a good joke is a good joke I
will never not laugh at a good job right
right it only gets it only gets a lot to
me when it's like you could tell that
the energy in the room is like it's easy
fall back so it's like when when
somebody when there's nothing to say so
you're just looking for something funny
and it's not even contextual but you're
just gonna dunk on it which is why Steve
is so not clever because like when he
has nothing to say he's like oh it's
just from a dancer that's his fallback
you can tell anytime he says that he's
been drinking too much because I'm out
drinking him and because he doesn't have
anything better to say in that moment
and then that's what translates but his
Classics man he him every time he says
shoe cobbler yeah no matter what so no
matter what you dude go on that [__]
like I will I will internally I'm dying
every time it's hard because that's
getting such a freaking Pro that you
can't even like he's yeah the way the
way Steve [__] can throw out [__] I'm
dying on the inside so much and then
there's this part of my like maybe my
dancer exoskeleton yeah that's like
trying to be all tough and stuff still
because if I crack up that also just
means I got owned owned yeah it's so
hard not to serious but it's like dude
the guy this is like his skill like he's
like improv you know what I mean it's
like right no way people in the fans
like yo Anthony should clap back I'm
like
you put on the put on a hip-hop song
Let's Dance battle maybe you know what I
mean I'm not in my element this guy's a
pro you know it's funny man so it's it's
just funny but Steve uh again on a long
form segment I [__] love Steve like
yeah me and Nina sleep at his house him
and Nikki like he's me and him he's been
helping me with the crypto Journey since
like you know over a year ago like we we
know each other like in ways that like
we've never gotten a chance to share all
right that's why he loves playing it up
because it's so not actually true
outside of the yeah I know that if I'll
hit him up for anything he'll help me
out if he needs anything like I'm there
yeah he's such a good dude that's what
makes it funny uh just because we and
it's it's all our fault we give the fans
what we give the fans if we don't give
them the other side they're only gonna
react to us the fans aren't dumb or
anything they just know what they get
and it's cool that the hardcore fans
like understand that it's just a bit but
like when you see comments that of
people are like yo anthy's really
getting bothered and then Steve's there
to reinforce it yeah that guy can't take
a joke well like he just loves playing
it up because it's so far from the
actual truth yeah no it's no the funny
thing is that it's not far from you
the funny thing is I am sitting there
getting roasted by an actual comedian
and I don't have much to clap back on
you know what I mean and I'm just like
oh man this guy is really talented at
this yeah he is it's like when are we
going to be in my Forum what are we
going to be on oh of course people have
been asking for that for so long they're
always like yo make Anthony like teach a
dance but even then it's not like you're
gonna watch these guys dance and be like
haha you suck I know yeah they're not
gonna they're gonna get credit for it
yeah yeah that's true which which would
be hilarious by the way you know getting
getting these [__] up they they
can't they got like two left feet you
know what I'm saying like Bart being so
buff like his muscles will move better
than his like Rhythm it would just be so
funny to get them to dance but that's
not the point the point is people come
and they want to see our [__]
personalities on the show and that's one
of that's just interesting that that's
one of the manifestations that I would
have never known because as a guest as a
guest right it was it was very very few
and far in between because I was here so
like not frequently like there was a lot
of respect you know nothing is
disrespect now but there was a lot of
just like you know oh yeah yeah dunk on
a guess hello you want to up them you
want to make them feel good right that's
why you're here yeah and then now you
come regular and you're like yeah this
is my family and then everybody's
dunking on you and it's [__] funny
dude I mean that's how it is like like
Nick said about his ears he's like
they're gonna dunk on you no matter what
yeah you know
but I honestly I I love this groups yeah
me too it really is so dope I love the
whole thing like I hated it at first
like not when I came on as a host but
the first time I came on as a guest and
I remember I thought it was so fun and
then like 2009 yeah or two thousand like
early 2000s I think 2014 yeah because my
news wasn't around till like 12 or 13.
yeah 2014 2015 I came on as a guest and
uh I was like that was fun and then I I
remember my cousin was like hey don't
read the comments and I was like why
he's like yo Their audience is mad toxic
and I was like how do you how is an
audience toxic they were watching the
show and then I looked at the comments I
was like
every person just was making fun of me
like who the [__] is this guy this guy
sucks like I didn't even say anything
for most episodes they'd be like what a
loser this guy looks like an idiot like
everything was like so negative and I
was like what is the point of that why
would that be a thing and then over time
like
um and then Joe had like was explaining
it to me later he was like yeah
um we went way too long not checking the
channel on that like not cleaning house
because I remembered um when I mentioned
that now like oh the audience is so much
better now and Joe was like yeah that's
not a coincidence it's like we had to
like it festered for so long this like
weird negative vibe with the audience
and they operated on that and now like
those people are all gone and now the
people who weren't talking back then
because they didn't want to chime in on
that [__] are now the People speaking
totally I mean you know like just a
little bit ago we were talking about
like first right like even in an
industry like the dance community and
stuff like that yeah being like oh we
didn't even know that like people were
watching these YouTube videos that we
were sharing right same thing I think
I think we were like even JK news was
submitting itself to an Era that people
were like the keyboard Warrior yeah yeah
right this is the generation that that
developed the first keyboard Warrior
that's true the first people that ever
like you know behind the the comfort of
their username and a different IP
address location right you could say
anything in your freedom of a speech and
never be inconsequential yeah
inconsequential even if somebody didn't
like your thing it would do nothing to
your physical nature yeah so people had
this like just this armor on they could
say anything right right and so if you
did participate in like some sort of
online form like a JK news comment
section yeah say whatever the [__] you
wanted to and not get checked like like
Joe said like you know just leaving it
and not really checking that into the
right community
of course you're gonna have the most
toxic people yeah you know I mean JK
news comments was like [__] League of
Legends toxic you know what I'm saying
yeah it's a college Lobby people were
just going off because they could yeah
because it was the nature of the
conversation sometimes right right yeah
yeah yeah so I don't know if you were in
the room when I I think I told the guys
this but I got really like affected I
asked this one dude who I thought was
really cool I was like oh he's a Creator
on like Tick Tock and stuff and I was
like oh this guy's really cool like I I
I [__] with stuff and then I asked him
like yo would you ever want to like come
on to JK and then he was like yeah man
like I've been a fan of JK forever like
that JK's like to go blah blah all good
things to say and then I followed up
with them like a few weeks later and I
was like hey you're still down to come
on and his tone was like completely
different and he was like yeah no I'm
not even I can't even be on that [__]
like it's it's not what it used to be
but like like I think he like either
someone got to him and like said
something or he looked it up and just
didn't like what he was seeing and then
so rather than be like oh well [__] you
then I was like yo can we talk and like
can you just tell me a little bit about
why you don't like the channel and then
uh because I really wanted to know like
what what's behind us this was uh yeah I
was already hosting and but um this
seemed like a good chance to actually
get a good uh look on like what's wrong
with it from his perspective and then he
uh broke it down like for me and was
just like yeah
um
one of the things was like he he said
that JK does not defend when people are
talking [__] about the guest which is
true
and um like when we have a guest on and
nobody knows them people automatically
tend to be like who the [__] is this
this person sucks because they haven't
won them over
um especially if you lead with like an
article and not an OTR on a person's
appearance yeah like who the [__] is
this guy you know like out of nowhere
there's no intro about which we got to
do better on them which yeah but um that
was one thing and I was like oh that's a
good point another thing he was like oh
the opinions aren't different like they
used to be like Hive minded everybody's
on the same page with stuff yeah which
is like some [__] you kind of are on the
same page but maybe we don't express
enough that we are even though uh or
that we aren't I don't know but uh
that was one thing that he didn't like
and then he was like oh look also
there's like some [__] that's like
borderline like racial or whatever
that I was like that might have been way
before my time I haven't experienced
anything like that since being here
um and uh and yeah and he just
completely declined to like [__] with it
and it just was like nah but then like I
get it yeah you know I mean it's not
wrong no yeah I was like thank you I'm
like I'm glad you you were able to speak
your opinion and I wanted to like kind
of take that and see if like what we
could use from that one of the main
things really was the lack of uh
presence in in comments too was just
like people are allowed to say whatever
they want
too much not like we should just like no
you guys can't say that but like we
should still weigh in beyond the video
like if people are saying something bad
about you know a guest or something like
the fact that they might go look at the
video themselves and go wow everyone's
just dunking on me and JK's not here to
be like No actually they're cool yeah
that's that is a tough thing I mean one
we should definitely always throw out
new guests otrs before regular articles
that's
in order with our production schedule so
that makes sense because it's a story
for people you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
for long time followers and stuff that
like are are diligent with like the new
uploads you there is a little bit of a
chronological order that helps with that
right yeah I remember when Jesus was on
uh-huh oh yeah that was a weird one yeah
yeah and all the first comments were
like I don't like this guy yeah people
just couldn't like they couldn't and
then by the time the third video comes
out like I love this guy yeah and then
people came around and they were like
he's cool yeah it's complicated again
everybody in general like you know maybe
I don't know maybe maybe the world in
general will be a better place with a
little bit less judging you know yeah
yeah everybody's very quick to judge
because you never know and we don't know
either too sometimes having a guest
doesn't guarantee that like everything
is going to click you know we're also
sitting in the room and organically and
authentically finding a flow with
another human being right right one who
is like
um in themselves just like we explained
when we were a guests like there's
already a camaraderie here there's
already like a chemistry and a flow with
like yeah five or six other people that
know each other and I'm a new guy in the
room sitting in the hot seats that's
hard yeah you know it's a very difficult
thing so any guess who survives the
session with us is a feat and people
need to know that you know that's what I
like I really like the fact that you're
just jumping into a grab bag of things
where like you don't know who you're
gonna get but you can appreciate the
differences and that's what I like some
people in the comments really do warm up
to that and they're like I just like
that I never know what it's going to be
yeah and it's not always going to be the
same yeah
um I gotta say just because we have this
forum uh
uh Mr anime what you have been doing
with these social media and uh more than
I think social media is actually too
um
it doesn't encapsulate the full thing I
think with the community I think the JK
Community truly exists today it's a good
Community yeah because of like what
you're also doing with the social media
you know I remember when it first it was
like it was before you were starting to
jump on social media where I was looking
at Joe and Barton I was like why why
aren't we posting anything on our social
medias like we we don't like we have all
these this content we're creating on The
Daily and the last JK news Instagram
video you have is from like the old era
of stuff oh yeah I haven't been posted
for months and I'm like we need to like
we're losing followers we're like
um we're literally just at this point
where things are going downwards and we
need to have new stuff and then again
back to my thing about being the biggest
fan of your IG stories and stuff I was
like I told him I was like dudes Ryan is
like the most genius guy I know in terms
of a way to answer the 5G stories dude
there's just there's something to it if
you [__] know what I'm talking about
you know what I'm talking about you know
you just like have some sort of X Factor
with it Indescribable right thank you
and then you know the second you start
actually doing our social media and
stuff what happens
the community starts growing this
familiarity you're like bridging gaps in
conversation there's there's an entry
point for people to communicate with us
where somebody on our side with the
account name is responding in kind you
know what I mean
um there's moments where you're willing
to in the IG stories like in between
breaks just say thank you to new
supporters or clarifying certain things
or you're reposting different guest
stuff that's not content from our
Channel but maybe it's like a comedy
show that they're going to be performing
oh yeah go watch this and that's like
nurturing the community and the
relationship with all the guests and
stuff and now you're seeing that like as
expansive as that goes from IG over to
tick tock you know we have hundreds of
thousands of followers on Tick Tock now
and things are going viral are YouTube
shorts being uploaded and like bringing
the subscribership back up to a
different level giving us new breath and
Life to a space where it makes sense to
like run patreon a different way because
you're actively in the Discord
communicating with our patrons like I
think that the community building is
truly a revolutionary and big change for
this JK new structure because straight
up your remember I remember we were
going out to Vegas you know what I mean
it was like when you formally got down
we were in Bart's gym in his own house
his old forever home yeah you know what
I mean it's like hey we got to make
forever home three I remember asking I
was like you know can we can we get Ryan
to be a regular because he's just yeah
our first like meeting all together yeah
you know it's just [__] good at what
he does and the energy is cool but now
seeing like where it's being able to go
like at that time where it was and where
the energy was I remember because it you
know we had just signed up to be like
full not full-time but like regulars on
it yeah and I I adjusted to be dedicated
to it yeah you know what I mean and uh
this is I this is obviously after you
know like Tiff left and stuff like that
and they there was like a host hole that
wasn't being right Steve just stepped in
because he was capable but it's not like
he wanted to host everything right
they're having this conversation right
here in this office at this table about
like not having like a host situation I
was like
uh hey I don't mean to be too forward
but I'm I think I could do this if you
need another host and they're so open
bar and Joe they're so adaptive and oh
that's how that happens that's really
how it happened and I was like I was
like I think I could do a pretty good
job they're like you sure and I was like
yeah I think I could do this yeah you
know I mean I've done some similar
things
and then my first hosting ever Dante
Bosco is the guest
that's funny to keep doing that it
happened to me too yeah so so like
Dante's guest and just straight into
hard mode yeah someone you respect we're
right into it and then [__] uh I look
at the video in the comments oh the very
very first video of my like my debut it
wasn't like Anthony's debut hosting it
by any means oh they just like cold was
like yeah but I was just curious about
it and like this was also in line with
like the time that you know uh and I'm
not gonna dive too much into it because
again I'm just going for my third party
perspective but you know uh
old host Tiff uh also like you know just
left so a lot of the fans were kind of
like split in between the Middle right a
lot of like drama that was like I wasn't
very understanding or privy to because
yeah because I had nothing to do with us
I just become a regular you know right
um and I remember thinking like people
were just so upset
in the comments and like that was my
first host job
that's a rough entry point yeah so like
it just felt like everything was like
this and I remember telling Bart yeah
cause you can't really win you know and
you know and you know all love to guys
like Barton Joe but like you know bar
he's obviously still building a it's a
giant Empire with like barbell and
everything that's going on Joe was going
he was deep in the trenches with
everything he's doing Waikiki up and all
this stuff like they're doing really
huge and amazing phenomenal things that
JK news was kind of like we were in a
deep pocket of some sort of lull we were
rebuilding our team from the inside out
and obviously a lot of fans were upset
and leaving right and you know I just
become a host of this like dying animal
yeah and I remember there was a point
you were almost like a human shield in a
way a little bit a little bit but I do
remember this this is the crazy thing I
looked at Bart and I I remember just
being like yo I don't want to be a part
of like a dying thing uh you know what I
mean like I I don't want to submit
myself to that right you know it's like
I'd rather be a part of like
um I don't care if it's low and down at
the bottom I just care that it's trying
and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
what I mean but like seeing
where it's gone and again a lot of like
credit to you and like what you've been
able to do with the community building
and social media and just Reviving
certain things you know what I mean in a
certain way just realistically also just
playing by the regular rules of today
exactly yeah yeah but like now like it's
a growing thing and it's it is beautiful
it's amazing the community and the fans
are like amazing the Discord is [__]
fun you know people are just like the
the regulars that come in and they're
supporting and like they're submitting
articles and like just it's just so
[__] cool now you know because uh the
patreon is growing the subscribership is
growing the followers on Tick Tock and
Instagram are growing the views are
growing like all of it is just working
and it's just it's just way cooler I
think it's harder too to to grow
something that's been around so long in
a certain degree like in a way that it's
always been and then now it's not that
anymore it's like yeah people are
Justified for going I don't like this
now you know it's like okay cool because
you're so used to this thing but for the
people that like are willing to accept
it and they find out it's actually
pretty freaking cool is like I love that
idea that like hey if you stayed around
long enough and you kind of caught the
drift of it and you enjoyed yourself
that's great I think that dude who like
kind of um explained why he didn't like
the channel really helped me a lot
because rather than like feeling like oh
we need to silence all these people
talking [__] it wasn't that it was we
need to
um we need to back the people up that
are saying good things about us and
doing that makes them feel like they
should fight harder for you yeah because
it's like hey like thank you for saying
that you love JK thank you for saying
that you've watched it for a decade
thanks for saying that you've been here
since uh Uncle chin like it's like the
people that say that [__] they're really
taking a moment out of their lives to be
like I want you to hear this and when I
looked back at the old messages that I
like that were never answered on the DMS
yeah I'm like dude there's some freaking
really valuable things and I went
through it and was just like thank you
thank you sorry we didn't respond in six
years like all these people that were
saying all these things that nobody gave
a [__] like nobody saw it that's what
I'm saying God damn man once you connect
with the fans in the community you know
what I mean like that's when it's like
the super fans are really the ones that
actually support and drive the yeah it's
not just about like you know when you
got like nearly 2 million subscribers
like we don't know 1.8 million of them
right you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
but like the the 10 000 that are like
consistently in like every new thing if
you drop a shirt they buy if you drop a
patreon exactly yeah yeah drop a video
they comment like that's what actually
keeps the whole thing going right you
know what I'm saying so just nurturing
that element like I don't know it's just
there's definitely a magic there's
something about the Attitude Era there's
something about the careful boys and
everything that's happening right now
that like I feel like it's brand new
it's growing and it's like [__] fun
to be a part of it is and it's in the
audience is so good like when you go to
other podcasts or other or anything like
does there's very few people that are as
like these people have been in here like
10 is deep like they're yeah down like
they are down they're not going to
change their mind about you overnight
and be like oh you're not cool anymore
yeah dude
yeah they're Way Beyond that it's like
that's way more value like you can't
build an audience like that yeah it's so
weird like back in um back to my [__]
UCLA Workshop I was just teaching that
yeah so funny we had this q a afterwards
everybody's like lining up take photos
and stuff like that people are just
saying things that they they just wanted
to share with me like Yo dude like I've
been watching you since I was six
do I excuse me wow like wait thanks for
coming yeah yeah how old are you now 20
I'm like oh whoa like that's a thing it
makes sense yeah and it's like that's
what something even like JK is just the
idea of even being one of like the first
channels to do something yeah like this
and again it's easy for us to talk about
maybe because we weren't the one the
guys who created so like being able to
also witness it gives us perspective you
know but like to see it being one of the
first in original kind of like YouTube
channel especially for Asians as well to
have this kind of like forum and
platform for people to speak
and still be alive is I think that in
and of itself
shouldn't be here in a different way
because now people like you said are
able to be like I grew up watching you
you're the one you're the group that
gave me you know what I mean my uh from
my childhood you guys taught me all this
XYZ you know yeah that's wild right that
people can learn from that I love
hearing people say that their humor is
shaped by JK in a way that they don't
take everything so seriously dude and
it's not even just like people who like
you know are like Asian people that are
yeah
right it's like it's like Philip should
be was on our Kansas podcast obviously
pack and
um he was very wholeheartedly expressing
how much he [__] loves JK because
he's like in today's hyper sensitive
world yeah it's not just refreshing it's
like needed yeah that a group of people
can it's unfiltered just speak because
it's not like we're [__] scripting
jokes and going off of something that's
like so Innovative right in all honesty
it's a lot of the like the internalized
societal regular feelings or thoughts
that people have we're just not afraid
to speak about it you know what I mean
so even when like you know homeboy is
talking about like oh you know things
are like racial and blah blah like I bet
you know I I beg to ask people in
society in general to like look at that
our most viral Clips on JK oftentimes
have to deal with race right it's not
because we're racial we're talking about
everything we're talking about
conspiracies to like space to like it's
all across we're talking about
everything we're not just talking about
race right but Society is holding on to
like those bites the most exactly or
have most comments because it's like
polarized and it's something they feel
like they can weigh in on exactly so
it's like that's
that's maybe some of the things that
most people tend to think are the
extremities they think the extreme
expressions are the things that
characterize what that brand or that
that group of core values is right but I
don't think that's necessarily the case
I think we uh JK is truly like
kind of a group of regular people so to
speak I know we're irregular but a group
of kind of like normal humans existing
in life on planet Earth that are just
speaking what normal people might also
be thinking or thinking about you know
and I think that's the power it's not
the magic like we're
you know presenting brand new news
before anybody else hears about it or
like we're right giving some sort of
perspective definitely not nobody else
thought about yeah no
speaking like regular people we're just
choosing to speak about it versus like
not you know exactly yeah that's true
yeah rather than just stay silent on it
the cool thing is I'm glad that they
trust us with doing this like Barton Joe
oh yeah oh I was like the people I'm
like I don't think they should trust us
yeah like I said there there's them
being adaptive recognizing like you know
how to uh encourage and and enable
people's strengths and momentum I think
there's got to be a reason why this
thing is still alive after like over a
decade you know what I mean it comes
from still like you know people that get
it you know exactly
yeah
don't
damn we're at two hours already nice I
like it oh yeah let's wrap this up let's
wrap this up but yeah I'm uh in total
I'm glad that we both ended up here man
like it's really cool I am too I I think
it was just the other month I was
telling Mike I was like I'm [__] glad
Ryan's on her because as long as I have
no ride this is like now the closest we
get to become yeah you know what I mean
which is like we've lived like this for
years and years and years but like for
JK for this to be one of the benefits of
it is like a win to me I'm like dude I
finally get to like connect with you at
a level that I've only seen in passing
yeah or I was too shy to go hey you want
to play video games it's yeah it's all
all cheesiness at the Forefront you know
what I mean like just
the older you get the the less of
opportunity you have to like make
friends or like to really connect with
people and you get very you get very
like protective of your space yeah you
know what I'm saying and like Jacob
gives us one a forum
to even bring on guests the fact that
there's really a space to bring on a new
personality or a new like networked
person builds relationships in like a I
don't know an adult play date way and
then on the other side of it it's like
we as a collective get to just develop
our friendships and detail yeah yeah
like that and as much time as we've
spent with the camera button on where
we're talking about stuff that's like
the same amount of time as when the
camera is off and we're talking about
random exactly you know what I mean so
it's like doubled that down and like
that's how much we're almost fast
forwarding our relationship building
because of the amount of time we're
putting into it but I don't know it's
just [__] cool I'm glad that we're
like doing things like this podcast and
just like finding new ways to not just
express ourselves and like have a
different kind of purpose in life but
like again back to the just connecting
with our community yeah is the most I
think enriching thing like really just
like you know everybody wants to belong
somewhere and have some sort of
connection is all you know and yeah I
feel like this is what I also personally
get selfishly from JK we just get to
connect with people especially I feel
like at this time in in the world where
like so many things are going wrong for
everybody I really like the fact that I
can sit in a room and we can openly talk
about how badly we're [__] up at
things
like it makes you feel better yeah
I would probably be depressed if I was
just thinking all these things yeah
honestly yeah but we literally get to
bring in the worst topics here and
somehow except for the ones that we're
getting canceled for somehow we're
cracking up about everything and I think
that's what people also need like in the
audience too they have their own stories
about how things are going so badly but
JK is there and we can all Relish in it
together and just you know be miserable
yeah I mean if we're all gonna go down
hilariously miserable let's just crack
up what we're going down yeah might as
well that's what this whole show is yeah
so thank you guys for joining us on the
first episode of uh JK overtime where we
go way over
without getting paid
that's just that's just the tagline
oh please subscribe please subscribe
right nice